more than 20 million Americans are in
the path of a powerful winter storm and
life-threatening low temperatures this
morning blizzard and winter storm
warnings are in effect across the
Midwest more than a foot of snow is
expected in some parts of Minnesota and
Wisconsin more than 700 flights are
already canceled this morning a blast of
frigid air it's known as the polar
vortex is bringing record low
temperatures to the Midwest and
Northeast this week by Wednesday at
least 55 million people will face
temperatures at zero or below Dean
Reynolds is in Highland Park Illinois
Dean good morning good morning well
we're expecting about nine inches of
snow here today and you can see the
streets and sidewalks are being cleared
right now even as I speak and it will be
followed by mercilessly low wind chills
and I'm talking about 50 degrees below
zero later this week meaning anybody
outdoors for long is risking frostbite
the arctic blast punished travelers
across the middle of the country in Erie
Pennsylvania whiteout conditions caused
a mess on major highways oh wow this car
is not good
plows were working overtime in Cedar
Rapids Iowa overnight where heavy snow
made roads nearly impassable for dry
stunning drone video shows the impact of
below zero temperatures on Lake Erie
with ice sheets and dunes forming over
85% of the lake bundle up dudes need to
do the bitter cold is prompting
emergency warming shelters to be set up
across the Midwest to the Northeast for
those in need EMTs in Milwaukee have
seen an increase of 15 to 20 calls a day
from the freezing temps frostbite
hypothermia and just people just being
out in the elements Chicago Mayor Rahm
Emanuel says the city is working around
the clock to make sure warming areas are
staffed and people are safe the city is
going to be up running it's going to be
safe for the residents that is our
number one goal now this area could see
some of the coldest weather in decades
this week the actual record low
temperature in nearby Chicago is 27
degrees below zero set in 1985 and we
could be in that range on Wednesday
bianna not a record you want to break
dean thank you and stay warm